chapter 4 starts out originally asking
about Jewish identity what does it mean
to to be Jewish yeah this is not a
simple question to answer there's really
a number of different ways you could
answer this you could say it's to belong
to a religion to practice that religion
but is everybody who's Jewish observant
there many secular Jews what makes them
Jewish done you know a lot of the people
who who actually got rounded up in the
Holocaust didn't think of themselves as
Jewish they'd actually converted what
else could make you Jewish yeah yeah and
the rule of thumb is its descent through
the mother although you notice that the
anti-semites have not observed that rule
is anybody's got your eyes Jewish so
you've got ethnicity you've got religion
does that cover the entire gamut
cultured could some of that somebody
could be culturally Jewish they can be
adopted into a Jewish family that's not
religious and they're not actually
ethnically jewish you know but people
might might consider them a Jew a lot of
it has to do with this this long term
narrative or is her story and he talks
about different terms that people use
Jewish Hebrew and where they come from
we don't really need to worry about them
weary starts out with is in terms of
these people call the patriarchs the
beginning of the story would be people
like Abraham
and Abraham doesn't start out Jewish
does he he starts out living in one of
the what movie nowadays called Iraq in
one of these towns along the Tigers from
Euphrates and according to the story God
says leave that town which to em would
be sort of like you know a lot of people
who are like who grew up in New York
there's a lot of people just for the
Chicago the can't imagine living
anywhere else I totally missed the city
you know imagine like sticking them off
in in Schenectady or in buffalo or you
know or even you know not even city just
some little tiny town and they they're
like that's that's that's like death to
me I don't excite you up in the
countryside but so I know its charms
imagine that for Abraham everything he
knows is in this city and this God says
to him all right I want you to take off
and try to take some of your relatives
with you try to talk them into that
that's the beginning of the story and he
doesn't he follows the call and there he
has all sorts of adventures that you can
read about the book of Genesis some of
them quite quite interesting and amusing
some of them harrowing and he ends up
being promised this is wholly Lee right
and when he's when he's an old man he
has two sons Ishmael first by his wife's
handmaiden and then Isaac and the Jewish
people descends through through Isaac
who by the way God tells him at one
point sacrificing i mean this this is a
story and it's got lots of twists and
turns well worth reading if you haven't
done that isaac and then and then your
stories of him and jacob also known as
Israel
Jacob has a bunch of kids one of whom is
named Joseph each one of these are what
we call patriarchs one is a patriarch a
father father figure it was important
who's an example Joseph is the one by
the way to gets them to go to Egypt says
you know because there's a lot of fam
and at the time he says I've got a good
position down here why don't you all
come over here and they do that's where
the the story of the Exodus so let me
get this guy Moses one of the most
important of the Patriot and it goes on
from there your book talks about a lot
of these these stories give you a little
thumbnail sketch of them why is Moses a
particular number 10 then it kills the
Egyptian and Charlton Heston played and
he's a tough guy by the way Moses is a
tough day he beats up people keeps order
kind of an interesting guy they say
Ismail you were need for him plus we
actually read Exodus it gets involved in
some scrapes why is he so important what
happens thank you mm-hmm it's actually
not just just the type of man that's but
all the rest of them because he's
traditionally understood as the guy who
receives a tour on and writes it down
yeah there's what what calls a fail
funny it means God of hearing to
somebody and the Ten Commandments the
time words the Bekaa logia come out of
that and those are understood as being
normative for Jewish light in fact that
entire hoorah as a way of living is
supposed to come about that through that
and what else happens with this Moses
guy kills an Egyptian takes a lot about
the end of the story yeah yeah he comes
back and says let's get out of here and
you know the Hebrews at that time we're
not having a good time they're slaves
and the Egyptians are really impressing
them so they say let's get out of here
and they do and then what happens
remember the rest of the story comes to
a turning point doesn't it because the
the Pharaoh at first there's all these
plagues before that and that's why they
said now you can go and then the Pharaoh
says I changed my mind go get those go
get those slaves and bring them back and
they're getting up with chariots and
guys who have armor they're just going
to kill we're going to slaughter them so
things look pretty damn what happens up
yeah right see ya and this was one of
the central events that your book talks
about this experience of divine
deliverance that's what the book of Acts
in this city is centered around this is
what he calls a root experience every
year this is supposed to be sort of
remembered and re-enacted a miracle is
supposed to take place and this is not
only like well thank thank God that we
actually got out of that scrape now the
Egyptians will leave us alone that's not
the end of the story to they've run into
this people here and have trouble with
these guys and they count like at its
attack them and you should read the
whole book something about the nature of
God is revealed in this that's part of
what he's talking about here and there's
three things that that he emphasizes the
text book writer says in contrast with
the religious systems of the other
ancient Near Eastern people's the god of
the Hebrew people was the only guy with
whom they're allowed to have a
relationship so when we talk about this
question put this in your Jewish
identity what I did with monotheism
monotheism connected with o Jehovah by
the way is a sort of just a little story
and how people want to say Jehovah for
Yahweh it has to do with
the way it was written down and how it
made its way into German and then
English we can talk about that story
some other but they're referring to the
same thing so yah weight is the one God
that the Jews are supposed to have a
relationship what's unique about this
he's concerned with human history if you
look at the religious systems of other
people Canaanites Egyptians the
Babylonians people that are around the
Greeks later on these guys are not
particularly concerned with history with
human history with with particular
events there will be important stories
where Jews came down over here and
usually Zeus is knocking somebody on you
know the hero gets born that's way like
ninety-nine percent of the story Zeus
end up that's what the Greek heroes
usually come from every once in a while
somebody else you know some other God
will do it but they're not things like
yeah he rescued the whole people by
parting the sea and telling them to get
out of Egypt and then took them to this
promising that's historical stuff the
other thing that's important that he
comes out is Yahweh is understood as
being a personal God personally
connected with the individual people who
he carries more is communicating with
however you want to put it that was
something quite different than a lot of
ancient religions quite a few the
ancient religions there wasn't this
sense of being in an individual
relationship and the relationship was
understood in terms of this term so
there's kinds of the Covenant when you
make a covenant it's an agreement
between two parties so it would be some
examples of this you know that is we
have contracts if
oh I know exam when do you get it signed
contracts all the time in your daily
life that you probably don't need and
I'm not criticizing it to that away the
mirror iTunes itunes and what else what
was a broader thing I don't know what
anytime that you do what license
agreement license and upgrade agreements
right itunes will come out with a new
version you gotta you gotta click the i
agree thing websites do this you are
actually entering into a legal contract
most of them how many of you actually
read all of the things that you're
clicking how many of you read like the
first paragraph of these I i did that
none of you read the first paragraph
only a few computer you should at least
read the first paragraph it's not
something like I agree to pay you a
thousand dollars a month or something
like that those are those probably would
be legally binding anyway but those are
contracts they're giving something
you're giving something there's an
agreement that's being made with the
Jewish religion and this carries forth
into Christianity this notion of
covenant is really central Yahweh says
that he is going to care for these
people that he will either protect her
their guide and lead them through the
right way to live but they've got to do
some other things in return they can't
just you know say oh thanks for the gift
All Right see you later they're supposed
to be connected with them they're
supposed to be actually living out the
law yeah you know if you read these
biblical books like judges are well the
books with profits you see constant
back-and-forth where books of kings two
people are not doing what they're
supposed to do and then you know the
contract has to be someone reinforced or
reworked book of Hosea if you only read
one more confirms of covenant that would
be a great book to read because it's
looked at in terms of
Eric and Hosea is actually told to go
off and marry a harlot what we've got is
called horn to be his wife why because
that's the way Israel behaves towards
God and there's a whole story that I
don't want to do it for you back by
going into that this is actually good
place to talk now about the actual texts
again there we already talked about the
tour Rob right these first five books of
the Bible that includes these these
stories these legal codes what else is
there there is historical writings and
you know like like most ancient history
it's a mixture of history and some some
reinterpretation and ideology and some
sometimes wishful thinking but there is
actually historical quarter for a lot of
these texts like the book of Judges book
of Joshua chronicles Kings those sorts
of things and they're sort of narrating
the story of what's going on between
Yahweh and the people of Israel and
Judea by the way they also refer to
books that we don't have often times in
the books of kings it'll say yeah this
guy who did this stuff and if you want
to know more about him go and look in
this book over here there's no longer
exist unfortunately the prophetic books
the prophets are people if we if we look
at the the lexical meaning of this term
who speak for God quite often they
didn't feel like doing that a great
example that would be Jeremiah who
really was very reluctant prophet
because he knew that was going to get it
in all sorts of trouble because
generally what our profits telling
people are they saying all right good
job there were prophets who were doing
that those are the false prophets
what a prop is usually doing I'm going
around and telling people what yeah
they're giving them a bad performance
review this and you're screwing up
here's here's what you're supposed to be
doing here you're supposed to be doing a
here's what you're actually doing be
notice the big gap between these by the
way the guy upstairs is not really happy
about that and some things are going to
happen if you don't actually get this
this discrepancy reconcile them putting
it very you know businesslike talk here
that's that's essentially what's going
on a lot of these books and then they
tend to turn around things like you're
abusing the poor you're not supposed to
be charging people all this interest
that you're charging them and basically
putting them into slavery through debt
and you're doing that and God doesn't
like it that's what some of the books of
the prophets are talking about you're
not supposed to be oppressing the widow
and the orphan it's easy to do that
because there's nobody to protect them
but you know that's not what you're
supposed to be doing there's all sorts
of things along those lines some of them
we have to do with worship of other gods
adopting practices from other people's
but a lot of them have to do with ethics
well I'm about to do with failure zone
on the part of the Jewish people to live
up to that and by the way the prophets
are not just sent to in these books are
not just sent to the Jews any of you
remember the story of Jonah guy gets
swallowed by the whale remember that one
from like Sunday School he was a perfect
example someone who didn't want to be a
prophet he actually you know whatever
happens with this sea creature why does
it happen because God says I want you to
go here and he actually goes in the
exact opposite direction by sea and then
you know they throw him overboard and he
gets swallowed and then he could spit up
right where he's supposed to be and
where is he supposed to be it's not
Israel
anyone anyone know not even remotely
close to Nineveh with these dirty
Assyrians who have no conception
whatsoever about Yahweh and worship all
these other gods and you know he's got a
reasonable case ears like what the hell
are you sending me here you know it's
one thing to be a prophet to your people
but you're sending me to these chokers
over here and so he actually like
delivers the message and these guys they
actually like follow it and then he's
ticked off he's like you're going to
smite them you know I was waiting to see
that because they weren't going to do it
I knew you were favored couldn't do what
you said but then they did it what
what's wrong with this picture and then
God says the end I'm not a very
satisfying answer I'm god I want to save
them I can it's not just the Jews that I
care about it's also these uh these poor
minna bites over here there's a very
interesting prophetic story that's the
sort of stuffy of finding these
prophetic books and then finally there's
the other stuff often called the wisdom
literature yeah this includes like a
book of Job and if you ever read the
book of Job sometimes you actually have
to read it like in literature classes
it's actually very philosophical the
song of songs the first bits of erotic
literature that you can find in a few
big ones you're going to find in the
Bible the metaphors are quite juicy
about marriage proverbs Ecclesiastes the
Psalms the Psalms were used for for the
rituals of the temple they're actually
songs some other books he talks about
that didn't make it into the later
Jewish canon of scripture would be like
the book of the market the books of the
Maccabees the first and second one those
are historical books about the struggle
against the greeks other wisdom
literature like the book of wisdom and
book of ciroc one of the longest books
also called ecclesiasticus the book of
Tobit which is another story what few a
few other bits and pieces of some some
books and there's a whole story why that
they lowes didn't make it in but I think
I'll sort of reserve that for a little
bit later on when you're talking about
Catholics in Eastern Orthodox now let's
shift gears a bit and hopefully 11 of
time we talked about the patriarchs
we've talked about these tasks and all
those inherited stuff now I want to talk
about some some history and the history
begins and what he's talking about what
we're going to call the Miss Bora and
remember i use this term Lance class
diaspora come from the word you know to
the cast Steve they're cast some things
widely yeah it wasn't just you know the
African slaves who were spread all over
the place through the Caribbean South
America North America the Jewish people
long before that were spread all over
the place and why was that well part of
it had to do with being conquered you
know jus dania as a kingdom was
conquered by one of the great Middle
Eastern powers at the time and a lot of
the Jews were carried off in captivity
what was called the Babylonian captivity
this is a common practice by the way in
ancient imperial administration you
would take a lot of the people you think
of you the trouble makers will offer
their land disconnect them from that put
them somewhere else where they'd stay
out of trouble so that you know the
Babylonians was basically doing you know
my ruling 101 by doing that in any case
the Jews end up getting scattered all
over the place some of them fight is
mercenary slow ahead
you know there was actually a Jewish
temple that they've discovered an
elephantine Egypt which is very far
south why is it there because they're
done a long-standing presence of Jewish
mercenary soldiers guarding that area
Jews are spread all over the place
throughout the Roman Empire throughout
the Persian Empire they they scatter and
he he talks about fitting in as best as
they could have the host cultures in
which they dwelt he also talks about a
couple other things and I'm not going to
answer on the little book which is not
in very good shape so don't like you
know knock it around too much this is a
set to agent this is a copy of Jewish
tax but all in Greek because one of the
main places of the grief that the Jews
spread out through was the Roman Empire
in the Roman Empire lamb was only spoken
in the West most of the Roman Empire it
was Greek that was spoken yeah so this
is a this was somebody else's and they
cared for it very well before I got it
and I got my hands on it and this is
what I what I want to read Jewish texts
and grape as a cannon Hebrew was what I
read them in so I'm gonna pass not even
look at it very old and he talks about
the importance of this this by the way
is going to play a role in the
conversation about why the canons of
Scripture ended up with it off into
Mike's first place he then talks about
two groups two main groups of you might
say Jews in the Diaspora or the blank
and he does remark on on the importance
of Babylon
Middle East so recently there's been a
huge Jewish presence throughout the
Middle East but Jews are also spreading
in two other very important ways and he
talks about the arden Sephardic Jews
yeah what we're talking about there is
North Africa and the irryan Peninsula so
we're talking about nowadays Spain and
Portugal right then he also talks about
the so bad was spelling
the Ashkenazi Jews and these are
scattered originally in the Roman Empire
and then welcome to what's going to
become Germany and then spread to poor
pants washer lithuania is particularly
important he doesn't mention this in the
book but but actually the history of
languages fits in here too because it
offered a ditch right Yiddish is
actually a lot of people don't like you
to say this it's actually a dialect of
german some German speakers pretend like
they can't actually understand if it's
pretty it's pretty close and Yiddish was
was something that was spoken by by the
Ashkenazim because they were in that
environment it was a dialect there was
another dialect called Latino which was
actually it's got sort of the same
relation between Yiddish and German
between Ladino and the romance languages
and it was another dialect that was used
by the Sephardic what do you remember
about your medieval renaissance history
what happened in spain a little bit
later on that's part of what goes on
what's a broader things yeah
yeah first Muslims conquer Spain and
originally the suparna by their under
Muslims they weren't always totally
enlightened you know Moses Maimonides
actually have to get the hell out of
Spain and what as far as Egypt because
he was being persecuted by Muslims in
Spain but for the most part the Muslims
were pretty take it or take it leave it
very easy going what happens after that
who takes over Spain yeah for a name
there there a little bit look around but
they're part of this process of what's
called the Reconquista Reconquista
Christians Roman Catholics of Muslim
Spain and when they come in they
actually kick the Jews out and so a lot
of these supportive go to a place that's
by the way at that time actually Spanish
which we call the other words or hollow
after a while the Dutch you know got
sick of the Spaniards and kicked them
out to became independent and from there
they go to Dutch colonies as well what
was an important Dutch column we want to
take this back to their beauty him where
we're sitting in it right now New York
at that time it was that New York but in
the Amsterdam very good and so some of
the Jews actually end up in the American
continent through this long process of
getting out of Spain and you know going
to a free replace the Netherlands and
finding things that they would you know
work out that way there's there's a
number of different diff there's a
number of differences between these two
groups and part of it is their their
history these are the ones that suffer
because of the Holocaust for the most
part there's a huge Jewish presence for
a long time enjoy
Germany France Russia Poland Lithuania
yeah and as anti-semitism you know Rises
or becomes more virulent in Europe in
the 19th and 20th centuries what's your
backup he talks a bit about gatos you
know these were areas where Jews were
you know basically confined to they
couldn't be part of the larger society
and you know enlighten times the sum
artem didn't undergo that sort of
segregation but in these countries the
Jews tend to be segregated off into
ghettos or living in villages that
called shuttles yeah what ends up
happening is really a few elements to
the story a new movement action to new
movements come out of this that we're
going to very quickly touch on one of
the Hasidim who will talk about more
later on the set of Judaism really comes
in large part out of this area it's a
reaction against rabbinical Judaism
rationalism is a rationalism or
enlightenment considers them is a
mystical movement rationalism or
enlightenment as the drink is the
European enlightenment is going on a lot
of Jews are saying hey Judaism is
perfectly suited to this it's a religion
that's you know monotheistic all about
ethics and so they try to sort of strip
away all the cultural or ceremonial
elements to it the other thing that that
occurs it's very important in this
respect is anti-semitism eventually
culminating in the Holocaust we're about
six million Jews were helped by the
Nazis and other collaborators that
radically changed
jewish demographic dynamics where did
the majority of Jews today live anyone
know there's two two places two
countries yeah here here in Israel yeah
in larnaca because of European Jewry was
for the most part wiped out by the way
the Nazis were not the only ones to be
doing this a lot of Jews found their
ways into the Soviet gulags so you know
there's persecution taking place there
has been an evacuation in large part
from other parts of the world towards
Israel and toured the united states as
anti-semitism has arisen in other places
as well and the last thing to imagine
that he brings up is this term Zionism
Zionism means this this notion that
Israel should be a state the Jews should
have their own home lay on the way that
you know the checks do or the way the
Germans do or the way that the you know
somali ins do pick whoever you like and
that they'll only really be safe if they
have it there was for a long time though
no homeland that was only recently
created we're talking about in the last
century after the Second World War but
this scientist movement was around for
her now I'm going pretty strong for
about a century before that's why there
was no emphasis blessing towards that in
the first place so in all this this
history wrapped up in one I know we've
covered a lot of stuff in your head it's
probably spinning a little bit try to
credit that just it